so right now in America one out of four
women is taking some sort of a
psychiatric medication and that doesn't
include sleeping pills this is just
antidepressants anti-anxiety meds and
also antipsychotics because of the way
we're living because we're not getting
enough sleep or enough exercise or
enough sunshine more and more of us are
feeling stressed and anxious and
depressed to meet criteria for major
depressive episode you need to be
depressed and down more days than not
for at least two weeks sometimes women
are down or depressed for 3 or 4 days
every month and it's important to know
that that is normal and it's natural and
it doesn't have to necessarily be
medicated away 80% of prescriptions for
psych meds and America are written by
non psychiatrists by internists and
family practitioners and GPS and you
know to really tease apart whether you
have a psychiatric history whether your
family has a psychiatric history whether
you've ever been on these medicines
before and whether you really need these
medicines or there aren't other ways to
get you to feel better that's a long
conversation that would take an hour and
internists don't necessarily have this
much time an antidepressant is not a
diagnostic tool it's not a test like if
you know you're not sure if you're
depressed or not but then you take it
into the press that you start feeling
better and you're like oh I must have
been depressed that's no more accurate
than you know taking an adderall and
discovering that you're able to
concentrate and focus better that
doesn't mean that you have attention
deficit disorder people get on these
meds and it turns out that they like
them they do feel happier more relaxed
and then they discover that there's a
price to pay for feeling happier and
relaxed and their libido is dampened
it's more difficult to climax it's more
difficult to cry they may not feel as
connected emotionally with people and so
over time some people decide you know I
don't want to be medicated anymore you
know I don't feel like myself
and then they discover that it's
actually hard to get off of
antidepressants I'll give a fixed
withdrawal as an example and you can
Google effects or withdrawal you will
see for yourself that they're kind of
bizarre symptoms that people have they
will talk about feeling brain zaps
electricity that shoots from their head
out their arms I've had patients say
they feel they feel their brain moving
around in their skull or their eyes or
sort of lagging
behind their vision you know weird sort
of neurological sounding side-effects
unfortunately the way that health care
is in America right now I mean it it is
a commodity it is a business it affects
the way that doctors and patients
interact and sometimes there's not
enough time to really be thorough and
have the harder conversations you know
what did you eat for breakfast this
morning how much sleep did you get last
night are you exercising it sometimes
it's just easier to hand over a
prescription